[Applause]
if it is you we have a lot to talk about
and this is not the arena for i want my
furniture back because i bought your
furniture for your house in Venice
my sister dated him so I have a little
insight and if it's not I am so sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
Cody explained the furniture drama after
his win
I bet our sister for a little while and
I lived in this this little kind of like
beach shack thing in Venice they came
into the house you need a bad you need
this it's not alike listen I don't like
I don't know they just started ordering
ordering these stuff and we just show up
to the hospital Lindsay wasn't ready to
let things go
taking a dig at Miley in the process by
posting an old photo of Allie and Cody
on Instagram writing when you realize
you failed and you settle for Less Cody
Simpson family is everything you won the
masked singer but you lost on your
future
she later deleted the post one more dig
Cody's subtle swipe at Miley's ex liam
hemsworth I'm very very very romantic
she had talked about how she hadn't had
that kind of an experience in a
relationship before
[Music]